hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play dead lab okay
this is a new indie horror game not much
to explain you know the drill let's look
how far scares I am ready
oh hello thank you for coming today we
will get started in just a minute oh
it's quite see what huh what the reason
I am so flabbergasted at Wow look at my
hands April 1st oh is this some April
Fool's joke oh so cool alright maybe how
does you know my name okay who is this
but what do you want me to do you need
to grab that flashlight on the table
next to you find a weapon okay Wow okay
the reason I'm so shocked is because no
offense of the game maker I was
expecting something of much lesser
quality than this that voice acting was
actually pretty good and the scripting
and animation was not bad either and the
sound and the environment is it's not
bad way okay I have look there's music
and ambiance and some sort of a setting
in some weird whitewashed intro very
cool I have a lot of high hope for this
maybe too much high hopes hello
seems to be blood in the sink but are
there water in the sink and blood below
the sink and blood in this corner don't
know why someone missed the toilet
you okay so Chris okay now I'm able to
do this so some guy on a radio Oh little
rats some guy on a radio is telling me
that everyone else is dead except wahoo
hang on there second there yeah oh baby
jump out of my skin I don't know why but
I wasn't ready for that one I should
have seen that one coming
hey now do you stop it you okay yeah how
are you communicating with me did I pick
up the radio ah risky to pick up
clipboard clipboard what are you talking
about a clipboard but I thought I was
trying to go up here hang on a second
OOP yup can I go up here can I smash it
with my face hello is there a monster in
here that I picked up a clipboard what
it is it what does that mean
uh-oh I know what I needed to stack the
boxes over here not over there duh oh
wow oh no no did now give it okay how's
about to say if I broke the game already
I would be very very very upset with
myself
huh okay here we go
got it got it got it got it got it got
it yep got it
okay there we go yeah okay thanks Sam no
wait my name was Sam what was your name
mr. doctor man I've had bad experiences
with doctors in the emmitt I've had bad
experiences with doctors in the past
okay there we go
honk honk wow this is actually pretty
cool I mean for a friendiy indie game
I've been I've been lucky because
there's been quite a few of really
interesting ones well chief to sprint I
figured that one out by myself but
there's been a slew of very interesting
actually well made games around
yeah oh okay you're ready to get blabbed
nope you're ready to get blamed I'm
gonna blow you away what the hell the
hell is that oh this is the oh this is
the door I just know wait what
what's with the footprint I'm confused
now where did I where did I come from
where did I go where did I come from
cotton-eye Joe search the barrel what
what did that say searcher oh shoot the
barrel not that barrel oh there we go
that was a hefty Wow Wow
what the hell those things spider
douches good golly get out of here so
this isn't like the typical any horror
game where it's Disney blargh you know
pop out at you oh no go down this
hallway oh no go down this other hallway
this actually has some game to it I see
you you gonna get lammed in the face
it's oh it's physically enabled physics
it's got physics hello done was that the
Slenderman detection noise I think that
was with that that port oh no I did it -
oh god damn Oh what are these
Oh again he surprised me was I supposed
to do haha how did he get there what did
he hide was he programmed to hide I'm
actually kind of concerned about that
okay so now this time don't go sliding
off into the doom okay I'm gonna stop
being a big dumb and probably maybe try
to get through this was that someone
making a bomb here
I got a gun I got a gun
blood here Wow god damn it those
shouldn't be so startling but they pop
out of nowhere you need to be very
careful when I enter these rooms now
because obviously he'll to the yeah oh
yeah
obviously they don't stand a chance
anymore the door has a which door you
didn't say which door had opened you
just said door this door
no okay ooh more scientists and health
yes somehow I up my wounds and I'm good
to go
evanka I could zip up my ugly haha okay
this door wait a minute this this was
closed before because Japan see that's
so cool remind me of serious sam book
shot signature oh yeah oh that doesn't i
heard that heard that I heard that who
do no no no no
my flies I don't work plus I don't work
I wish they had better sound effects in
it
nevermind this outer face is just fine
Wow
get him round blab asking you think you
want some of me do that you ready oh uh
I gotta make sure there's other Bobby
bow ski oh what's that oh oh that grab
em off you left your face the other
celery oh yeah that music kicks up a
notch
I'm glad we went into holy [ __ ] mode
okay BAM I'm guessing this is supposed
to be the boss level
I'm asking here Biscay anymore anyone
else wants some someone hiding in these
hidey holes in the corner no all right
that actually reminds me of Duman
actually so does this button ha did I
make it do that one huh Oh got a bad
feeling about this one
god damnit wow I've got that was such a
coincidence does such a great thing to
end on all those fantastic there's
actually some talent in this I mean a
lot of it was probably a lot of stock a
textures and models and stuff like that
but it was put together pretty well and
Rea ha ha ha why didn't you just say
that you made this game it was really
well done I have to say it was put
together a little there were some
cliches here and there with the jump
scare noise it reminded me of Slenderman
too much so I mean obviously I connected
with that and so they could have done a
better noise there but still it was
really good the voice acting was good
the setting was good the story was I
don't know but I mean it was good it was
good I can't complain about it now let's
wait until the end their credits
and that's it okay
still good check the link in the
description below if you want to play
this for yourselves and hopefully
there'll be more from this creator in
the future so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
mom
there
Oh
ah
now we're the big